além do som
boa noite
eu adoro biografias
eu poderia ouvir a biografia de cada um
aqui poderia ficar horas me deliciando
com os detalhes da saga de cada um
eu acredito que na biografia de nós
há momentos que são chave são
transformadores
então eu vou começar a minha biografia é
eu cresci no rio grande do sul
e eu era um menino muito diferente dos
demais
era um pouco mais sensível e eu não
tinha tanta facilidade com as brigas e
disputas que tinham naquela época
em um determinado momento da minha
infância passou a ser muito difícil ir à
escola passou a ser realmente uma
tortura uma grande dor e cada dia que eu
ia para a aula eu sofri algumas formas
de agressão física ou verbal
me sentia excluído e eu não levava isso
numa boa porque eu queria fazer parte
daquele grupo
então eu comecei nessa época acumular
muita dor e muito sofrimento e com o
passar do tempo eu fui aprendendo a me
relacionar com essa situação e lá pela
pré adolescência eu descobri que eu
poderia esconder essa dor deixar um
lugar bem escondido e começará a
aparentar algo porque eu queria muito
ser amado
queria muito ser integrado nos grupos
então eu comecei a agir de uma forma não
tão autêntica mas pelo menos eu tinha um
certo resultado de aceitação ou de
integração dos grupos
só que isso começou a gerar
uma sensação muito ruim de não estar
sendo eu mesmo e que até hoje é um
desafio pra mim em muitos momentos
porque ainda é muito importante ser
aceito pelos outros e o que os outros
pensam de mim quando eu tinha 20 anos
eu conhecia algo que mudou o rumo da
minha vida eu conhecia o teatro como os
amigos já falaram e no teatro eu aprendi
muitas práticas com o corpo
aprendi muitos jogos muitas dinâmicas e
os encontros eram de três horas e eu
saía com muita vitalidade e muita
vivacidade e naquele momento eu decidi
eu quero trabalhar com isso isso é
transformador
isso é vivencial e aí eu comecei meus
estudos e minha preparação no campo das
vivências corporais nos jogos atrás de
jogos cooperativos que mais pra frente
eu fui conhecer e nesse momento eu
percebi que era um campo onde eu mais me
realizava e depois de várias
experiências de morar em outros estados
eu acabei chegando em florianópolis em
2013 e depois de um ano em florianópolis
aquela criança que tinha sofrido tudo
aquilo que tinha passado por todos
aqueles pesos sentiu é hora de fazer
algo com tudo isso e não numa tarde
dentro do mar
lá de florianópolis me veio a idéia de
fazer um trabalho que contemplasse toda
essa alegria essa vivacidade essa
tecnologia das vivências em grupo
além disso ações de rua e outras várias
ações
foi nesse momento surge o amor em
movimento e começamos com cursos curtos
no hospital universitário cursos de dois
meses ou três meses o resultado estava
sendo incrível
as pessoas estavam se transformando
muito cada encontro de duas ou três
horas era tão transformador quando tinha
vivido lá nos meus 20 anos e alegria
muito grande de ver as crianças
interiores pulando
alegrando se divertindo e eu percebi que
aquilo era o que eu queria fazer
mas pra frente surgiu as maratonas do
abraço
onde nós vivemos numa praça e apenas
oferecemos abraços para todos que
estavam passando e vocês não imaginam as
experiências que a gente teve com essa
prática desde pessoas que diziam que
seus filhos não os abraçavam até pessoas
que estavam pensando em tirar sua
própria vida naquele dia
de tudo que vocês podem imaginar a
experiência da maratona os abraços segue
se expandindo e no final do mês vamos
ter maratona do braço em macapá no amapá
que me deixa muito feliz em 2015
depois de ter vivido uma experiência
muito forte de perdão como meu pai onde
eu tive que superar uma mágoa muito
difícil e ter estudado muito tema a
vontade que eu tive foi de oferecer isso
a outras pessoas
e aí nasceu o workshop ter do art que
ocorre no final de semana e já
realizamos ele em várias cidades como
brasília são paulo
aqui em santa catarina no rio de janeiro
em outra cidade e hopper duarte a gente
não pode ser que ele garante que a
pessoa viva o perdão mas com certeza um
final de semana inteiro dedicado ao
assunto faz mexer em muitas coisas e
refletir muitas coisas a respeito e em
ano passado eu conhecia o trabalho do
sagrado masculino quando pela primeira
vez eu comecei a abrir mais as minhas
rohner habilidades e é como eu estou me
sentindo agora aqui pra vocês falando
sobre a minha vida ea minha história
isso começou a ser muito criativo e eu
estou no meio desse processo então eu
estou compartilhando aqui um processo de
cura que está não está encerrado está
acontecendo
e essa fala aqui hoje é parte desse
processo então o tema do perdão
é o que eu vou falar hoje é um tema
muito mal compreendido
muito se fala a respeito
muito já foi falado pelas religiões sob
o ponto de vista teológico mas não
encontrava as respostas na ciência na
psicologia foi conhecer o trabalho do
doutor fred los kim da universidade de
stanford que já há muitos anos trabalha
com o programa de perdão da universidade
de stanford e o trabalho dele é
impactante é sobre esse ponto de vista
que nós vamos falar hoje ontem eu queria
que cada um aqui pensar se agora na sua
biografia
se tem alguma pessoa que você está
magoada alguma situação que está
travando a sua vida
tome aí três segundos para pensar um
fato uma situação que você ainda não
soltou não se liberou e isso é uma das
coisas que me fascina nas biografias
porque esse fato essa situação não é
apenas algo que deve ser extirpado
eu tenho a maior confirmação que dentre
essas coisas que te travão que são
difíceis ou essa pessoa que é difícil
perdoar tem um tesouro ali dentro que a
vida não te entregou essa situação por
acaso e que há uma pérola ali dentro
basta que o tempo a mostre então o que
essa mágoa que a gente guarda muitos já
falaram em mágoa como má água ou mau
sentimento amargo ela tem alguns efeitos
como ressentimento para a saúde que os
estudos científicos comprovam como
aumento da pressão sanguínea aumento dos
níveis de cortisol no sangue aumento das
chances de desenvolver doenças cardíacas
aumento das chances de desenvolver
depressão e insônia
já está comprovado cientificamente que a
mágoa e ressentimento fazem mal para a
saúde mas porque a gente guarda essa
mágoa
era essa a minha pergunta o que vocês
acham porque a gente guarda mágoa e
ressentimento dessas situações
investigando a situação pra chegar à
conclusão que a mágoa eo ressentimento é
uma espécie de resposta que a gente dá
para aquilo
de acordo com a maturidade
tem naquele momento é uma espécie de
vingança é uma espécie de revidar
ela nasce muito da nossa cultura bélica
da nossa cultura de rivalidade e de
muito conflito que a maioria de nós
cresceu de uma forma ou de outra exposto
a essa cultura
então a mágoa nos coloca sempre num
nível de stress e todos os efeitos para
a saúde derivados disso nós enfrentamos
e esse organismo não foi feito pra ficar
sempre no topo esse organismo foi feito
para ter momentos o stress não é uma
coisa ruim
se tem um bebê em uma casa em chamas
você precisa de muita adrenalina e de
muita é impulso muscular para ir lá por
sete dez minutos e salvar aquele bebê
daquela casa em chamas
mas fica o tempo todo no pico do stress
é algo extremamente destrutivo para o
nosso psiquismo para nosso corpo
e aí vem a necessidade do perdão e o que
é o perdão
o perdão é liberar essa mágoa
o perdão é como atravessar uma ponte do
seu eu magoado ressentido procesl em paz
perdoar é estar em paz quando as coisas
não acontecem como você quer perdoar é
um ato de coragem
dado que a gente vive num mundo muito
baseado na guerra no conflito no ódio é
muito fácil se vingar
é muito fácil ficar magoado agora pra
perdoar precisa de muita coragem
se a gente perguntar se pra mil pessoas
aí com uma prancheta na rua que é o
perdão a gente ouvia de tudo que perdoar
é concordar e aceitar o que o outro fez
perdoar e ser bobos ingênuo
perdoar é ir lá e dizer eu te perdôo
enfim que perdoar é a gente ouve de tudo
para esquecer é ter uma amnésia
isso foi me mostrando que o tema era
muito mal compreendido e me deu mais
vontade de trabalhar com este tema
então eu vou contar pra vocês uma
história do mahatma gandhi aquele ser
que viveu na índia
certa feita perguntaram pra ele quando
uma pessoa cometeu um ato muito em voga
lito por uma rádio uma grande uma
atrocidade pra ele
perguntaram pra ele kandy você vai
perdoar esta pessoa grande respondeu não
é a pessoa como como que você não vai
perdoar ela não vou perdoar porque eu
não me ofende se ofender
é a nossa responsabilidade ninguém
ofendi ninguém é a gente que se sente
ofendido ninguém magoa ninguém é a gente
que se magoa se fazer responsável pelo
que você sente é o primeiro passo na
liberação de muitas coisas na nossa vida
não é o que aconteceu que está te
magoando está te incomodando é a
história é a narrativa é a forma como
você vê o que aconteceu que está te
magoando não exatamente o que aconteceu
é a forma como você vê o que aconteceu
percebem a diferença e por estarmos tão
viciado nessa forma de ver o que
aconteceu que estamos ainda travados em
muitas coisas
e será que perdoar é esquecer o que
vocês acham
perdoar não é esquecer
inclusive não é bom esquecer porque é na
lembrança que crescemos que nos que
amadurecemos e que vamos construindo a
nossa compreensão de vida nossa
trajetória
perdoar é lembrar diferentemente daquilo
que aconteceu é um novo olhar sobre o
que aconteceu a gente poderia dizer que
a ressignificar início tempo é um grande
aliado porque o tempo vai suavizando e
vai te mostrando outras variáveis e
depois de um certo tempo que para cada
um é diferente você pode até ser grato
pelo que aconteceu
e será que perdoaria concordar que você
acha
teodora concordar perdoar não vai
concordar
imaginemos uma mãe que teve o filho
assassinado
é muito compreensível que ela fique
meses e meio revoltada com ódio e com
tudo aquilo que a gente falou níveis de
cortisol em insônia depressão aumento da
chance de problema cardíaco aumento da
pressão sanguínea e ela pode ficar um
ano dois anos três anos por causa do
filho que foi assassinado
mas se algum momento ela decide fala eu
não vou destruir a minha vida eu vou
soltar essa situação e ela perdoa
quer dizer que ela concorda com o
assassinato não percebam que perdoar não
tem a ver com concordar inclusive ela
pode tomar todos os procedimentos legais
necessários e todos os afastamentos
necessário não tem a ver com isso porque
o perdão acontece dentro da gente
e será que perdoar é ir lá e dizer eu te
perdôo não você pode ir lá e dizer eu te
perdôo e não ter realmente vivido essa
transmutação essa alquimia interna
porque é disso que se trata o perdão é
mau que mia interna é um novo sentir é
um novo sentido em relação aquilo que
aconteceu então por que a gente deve
perdoar
simplesmente porque você também quer ser
perdoado pelas coisas que você faz você
também é que tolerem os seus erros e que
perdoem os seus erros
se você está incomodado porque foi
arrogante com você
quantas vezes que você também foi
arrogante se você tem incomodado por
alguém que foi estúpido com você
quantas vezes você também foi estúpido
essa postura de nos acharmos tão
magnânimos e outro monstro é uma grande
ilusão erramos tanto quanto ele
todos nós estamos sujeitos a erros e
como saber que a gente precisa passar
por um processo de perdão pensa nessa
situação que você tinha pensado nessa
pessoa que você ainda não soltou emergem
você algum sentimento de peso de
de dor de sofrimento quando você pensa
nessa pessoa nesse fato nessa situação
se emerge sim você deve ir passar por um
processo de perdão se não imaginada é
porque aquilo é apenas uma informação
aquilo não faz emergir um sentimento
pesado aqui estão não apenas um dado na
sua memória
então o perdão é uma das coisas mais
incríveis é uma das expressões do amor
mais elevadas e desafiadores que existem
e por ele te dá tanto por essa liberação
que dá tanta alegria e tanto prazer e
felicidade no final ele exige também de
você uma certa dedicação existem alguns
trabalhos em algumas fases desse
trabalho que você pode fazer se você
está decidido ea primeira coisa é
exatamente isso decidir
enquanto você não decide que quer
liberar desse nó na sua vida o processo
não tem início e às vezes essa decisão
se dá por cansaço porque já estou por
aqui nesse processo já não aguento mais
ou então porque eu já tive que no médico
ou então porque já tive alguns
diagnósticos de doenças graves e no
fundo eu sei qual a origem disso o
segundo passo é ter algum trabalho de
contato com você mesmo conseguir ficar
em silêncio com você mesmo que seja dois
minutos sem respirar e se sentir o que a
gente chama de meditação ou a
interiorização a calma quando a gente
começa acalmar todo o nosso sistema
nervoso se reorganiza e hoje é preciso
fazer-se guerreiro para conseguir se
acalmar
é preciso realmente ter uma decisão
o terceiro passo é identificar
claramente o que você quer perdoar
coloque no papel a situação aí eu estou
magoado porque aquela pessoa que fez
isso e aquilo cuidado com as oposições
têm que ser muito objetivo quando você
for escrever o que você quer perdoar o
quarto passo na minha opinião mais
importante é a visão de conjunto
compreender o grau de maturidade de
todos que estavam envolvidos na situação
inclusive seu porque provavelmente não
tinha o mesmo grau de maio
a idade que você tinha outra época não
compreendo o seu grau de maturidade
naquela época e de todas as pessoas
envolvidas para isso recomendo que você
faça a biografia dessa pessoa
novamente a biografia a história de vida
pode parecer estranho mas se você está
magoado com o seu pai
tome alguns minutos e escrever a
biografia dele pega um papel e caneta e
escreva a história de vida dele
pergunte faça um trabalho investigativo
foi uma pessoa que não está mais aqui
entre nós pode ser um pouco mais difícil
ou alguma pessoa que você não conhece
muito mais procuro fazer o que você
puder essa visão de conjunto e aí você
vai se perceber se fosse você tendo sido
filho dessas duas pessoas que ela foi
filha vivida nas escolas que ela passou
na cidade que ela viveu tendo as
influências que ela viveu com a
maturidade que ela teve como você por
ter reagido
será que você teria feito diferente não
é como seria você no lugar dela
sendo você com seus recursos com a sua
maturidade não é isso é sendo aula com a
maturidade dólar
esse é um exercício que começa a gerar
dentro de nós uma grande transformação e
saibam as pessoas são resultado de tudo
que elas viveram
elas são simplesmente resultado de tudo
que elas viveram até hoje e ela fazendo
que elas podem com a maturidade que elas
têm o quinto passo é deixar fora de nós
saber que é não não tomar aquilo
pessoalmente saber que a pessoa está
fazendo tem a ver com ela mesma
isso é muito importante me ajudou muito
no processo com meu pai sabia que o que
é dele é dele o que era aquela pessoa é
dela é processo dela de aprendizagem
o sexto passo você já deve ter ouvido
falar no pano
você pode criar frases mesmo que possa
parecer falso mas você pode dizer eu te
libero ou eu te amo eu te perdôo e essa
frase pode ser repetidas muitas vezes
internamente é o seu trabalho de
liberação daquilo ea sétima e último
trabalho que a gente recomenda é fazer
uma lista uma lista de consequências
positivas daquele fato por mais estranho
que possa parecer
no meu caso depois de tudo que eu vivi
na minha infância
isso me fez voltar muito para o estudo
do universo interno das pessoas por
estudar psicologia da energia da
espiritualidade
eu ia lá buscar soluções porque eu
estava passando
então eu acredito que se você viver esse
amor tão desafiador que o perdão porque
é muito fácil uma pessoa querida
simpática é legal
agora mais uma pessoa que te machucou é
aí que surge um grande desafio e um
caminho que você abre dentro de você que
não tem precedentes e o campo fique do
planeta vai ser influenciado pelo
processo que você vai realizar
digamos que durante a sua vida você
consiga completar e consumar cinco
processos de perdão com cinco pessoas
próximas o que você teve situações a
serem perdoados
você estará contribuindo enormemente
para que esse planeta tão necessitado
desse grau de amor desse grau de
compaixão possa respirar um momento mais
de esperança e um momento de renovação
entre essa humanidade
e quando vocês conseguirem fazer esse
processo e olharem para trás aquele
sentimento que era tão pesado tão duro e
você conseguir respirar e sentir
aliviado
eu garanto para vocês que é uma das
sensações maravilhosas que existem
obrigado